(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Ми зараз на етапі розробки дизайну, і у
нас виникла така проблема, що ми не знаємо,
що писати в шапці профілю.
Ми питали у Сергія Олексійовича, але він сказав
тільки про монстропедію.
А що ще в шапці профілю повинно бути?
Ну, не профілю, а нашого сайту, нашого блогу.
Ви маєте нову панель меню?
Так, так, так.
А що він саме казав, з яких підпунків
це має бути загалом?
Ось він тільки про монстропедію сказав, що монстропедія
про кожного члена корпорації повинна бути.
Це тільки одна категорія, а інші не зрозуміло.
Ну, там може бути ще пошук, він про
пошук казав.
Ну так, я нескільки пам'ятаю, він говорив
про те, що будуть профіль користувача, що можна
буде десь там з боку екрану в кінці
буде доставити якийсь кружечок з логотипом, якимось картинкою.
І там було ще, ну загалом так, під
монстропедією, я думаю, це мається на увазі загальна
тоді сторінка, де будуть ці пости, які писались
в Блозі.
Тому я думаю, що можна почати з того,
знову ж таки, ви можете почати розробляти, ну
наскільки я пам'ятаю, якщо я пам'ятаю
правильно, то це був, має бути просто тематичний
блог.
Ну, тобто з тематикою корпорації монстрів.
І, тобто, ви можете легко почати з верхній
панелі.
Зараз я гляну, що у вас є за
завдань.
Ну так, тобто, логотип можна розробити, сапку туди
поставити, я не знаю, з боку можна в
дизайні поставити загалом профіль, там, наприклад, ім'я
користувача і його фото.
І на початку там буде логотип і якась
там кнопка головна, наприклад, також цілком підійде, я
думаю.
Ага, ну не забагато там всього повинно бути,
так?
Так, тобто, тут не потрібно робити остаточний варіант
одразу, ми можемо це робити поступово.
Так, так,
так, так, так, так, так, так, так, так,
так, так, так, так, так
Ми з Віталією вже зрозуміли, що ми хочемо
брати, спробувати платформу VIX, ну тобто онлайн інструмент
для створення сайту-блогу типу Ворпреса.
Чому вибрали VIX?
Тому що ми трішечки не зрозуміли, як на
GitHub можна зробити спільні репозиторії для того, щоб
в онлайні вдвоєм працювати над проєктом.
Тому обрали онлайн VIX, щоб ми могли вдвоєм
одразу робити і бачити якийсь результат, щоб ми
не плуталися, ну і щоб якось було легше
робити роботу в плані, ну, у цій організованості
такої.
Ну дивіться, загалом можна, також цілком робочий варіант,
якщо є бажання, то можна в п'ятницю
буде приділити на лабораторному завданні, лабораторному занятті, частину
якраз саме такий, як організувати програмування разом, ну
тобто якщо це дві або більше людей, як
це організувати на GitHub і що робити, тому
що наскільки я розумію, то VIX, мені здається,
це конструктор сайтів, і знову ж таки, як
Сергій Олексійович описував, може підійти цілком, все залежить
від того, як буде він кастомізуватися, тому що
якщо ви не зможете, наприклад, змінити якісь частини,
які будуть вимоги…
Олександр, у вас трошки…
Добре, дякую.
Так, тобто ти говорив, що тут залежить від
ступеню того складності, чи ви зможете зробити все
на VIX.
Тобто якщо ви спевнені, що з VIX ви
можете зробити його підповнаційний вебсайт, такий, який є
вимога, цілком можна використовувати?
Ні, ну просто, почувши від Сергія Олексійовича завдання,
то там немає нічого такого надскладного, що треба,
як він приводив приклад, змінювати таке, щоб, наприклад,
на F5 не було нової сторінки, якщо це
просто звичайний блог, але, ну, звісно, що там
під Monsterpedia все це, але це просто звичайний
блог без, там, якогось жорсткого функціоналу, то, ну,
VIX, можливо, в цілком підійти до цього.
Так, але тут ж, дивіться, з позиції того,
що вимоги можуть змінюватися.
Тобто ми працюємо в більш такому приближеному до
реальності підході, і може вийти так, що, якщо
ви представите Сергія Олексійовичу в наступну п'ятницю,
через п'ятницю, коли в нас буде кінець
цього спринт-аут, представите те, що ви зробили,
він скаже, наприклад, я хочу ось таке.
Тобто вам треба бути впевненими в тому, що
ви зможете реалізувати його вимогу на VIX.
Якщо зможете, впевнено себе почуваєте цілком, тому що
тут немає якихось дуже великих обмежень.
Ні, ну дійсно, що якщо зараз поки і
такі умови, а потім він скаже, що треба
там щось таке зробити, то, звісно, там вже
по-іншому треба буде думати, я не знаю.
Просто це, можливо, треба було б говорити одразу,
що ось такі може бути складнощі, я можу
там попросити ось таке, тому що у нас
часу не також так багато, що у нас
кваліфікаційні роботи, бо, наприклад, у мене теж кваліфікаційна
робота зв'язана з сайтом, і дуже зараз
складно вести, там два сайти буде, і там
такі вимоги, там такі вимоги, тому не знаю,
що ще додати.
Цілком можна спробувати, знову ж таки, всіх вимог
буде важко сказати, на початковому етапі є такі
вимоги, якщо ви зможете їх реалізувати на віксі,
то ось так.
Тобто, початкові вимоги ви отримали, ви можете пробувати
на віксі, знову ж таки, якщо ви почуваєтеся
достатньо впевнено працюючи на ньому.
Якщо ні, тобто ви очікуєте те, що ви
не можете якісь частини змінити, ну, тоді, звісно,
треба буде враховувати це, або тоді доведеться переробляти,
або розбиратися, як це зробити у віксі.
А так, ну, цілком ви можете продовжувати розробляти
дизайн за допомогою віксі.
Ну, це все змінилося, ми поки що так
не вирішили так зробити, а там, можливо, і
Python візьмемо, тому це ще не остаточний просто
варіант, це ми так розглядали, щоб було краще
реалізувати організаційний момент в віксі, щоб було легше
вдвоєм працювати.
Так, ну, то ви цілком можете почати працювати
з вікс.
Якщо у вас буде вже загальний дизайн, то
переробити його, наприклад, під той же HTML, CSS
буде не важко, тому що у вас вже
буде загальна ідея, і це буде просто, фактично,
скопіювати той же самий дизайн, або хоча б
частково і переробити.
Як я вже зазначив, якщо хочете, то можна
додати в п'ятницю, я пояснюю, як працювати
з GitHub, якщо це більше однієї людини, якщо
це, звісно, буде корисним.
Ну, давайте, звісно, це цікаво і на власному
досвіді, як це робити.
Добре, тоді в п'ятницю ділимося на трошки
часу і зможемо розглянути.
Але поки ви можете продовжувати з віксом, тут
немає ніяких проблем.
Добре, ну ми ще поки будемо вирішувати щось
таке.
Може прийдемо до пайту з новою статтю.
Цілком, ну тут можете змінювати, час у вас
ще є, тому тут, я думаю, що цілком
встигнемо.
Добре, які ще тоді питання?
Можливо, в команди другої є?
Ми поки думаємо над новим дизайном сайту, і
я не знаю, куди саме додати.
Ви маєте новість, куди кидати дизайн сайту?
Ну, в принципі так, сам дизайн сайту, тому
що ми там вже перекидали купу блоків, і
який саме колір буде використовуватись.
Дивіться, в п'ятницю, я думаю, що цілком
Сергій Олексійович, можна буде виточнити якісь деталі, тому
що я не думаю, що він буде відповідати
в групі.
Тому цілком до п'ятниці ви розробляєте, і
в п'ятницю ми цілком можете показати, які
є, як я зазначу, ми проведемо там 10
хвилин, я думаю, на початку лабораторного заняття, приділимо
стендапу, і там загалом ви зможете показати, чи
такий є дизайн, можливо, потрібно щось змінити, чи
загалом просто показати, що у вас є.
Добре, в першу команду ви також можете цілком
показати приблизний дизайн сайту, якщо він буде до
п'ятниці якийсь, тобто просто попередній показ того,
що, можливо, будуть якісь коментарі.
А якщо не вийде, то, знову ж таки,
це не є якоюсь обов'язковою вимогою, і
ви можете розробляти цілком в своєму власному темпі.
Добре, зрозуміло.
Добре, є тоді ще якісь питання?
Нема.
До п'ятниці може з'явитися.
Добре, тоді зупиняю.